okay we're back that's another day yeah
the day in the apocalypse sidetracks 38
this is 38 I think I forgot I'm not
numbering I'm just doing I just have to
worry about it we shouldn't have sit we
should have a number of the begin with
well I like to keep track of like you
know what I mean so numbers there okay
nonsense
yeah it's just like there's like an
unauthorized activity whatever talk
about [ __ ] out there [ __ ] [ __ ] up
man I'm watching the news they are
[ __ ] [ __ ] up out there they better
get this they better get this [ __ ]
together man [ __ ] this [ __ ] shuts
down too long you'll never be able to
get this [ __ ] turn back turn back on
they have to [ __ ] call out in Morton
Tom I don't know man that they had [ __ ]
closed down for quite a long time in the
Spanish flu thing and everybody got over
it that was a time that was a simpler
time well I kind of feel like that you'd
think people would go crazier back then
cuz they didn't have like the internet
or Netflix or anything like that to
entertain themselves with they were used
to it they were dumb maybe low
information people you know they weren't
dumb just that I remember what it was
like you know before the internet you
know back in the Stone Age just you just
did you probably thought dinosaurs walk
to the earth the same time mystery you
didn't know any better you weren't used
to that kind of convenience you weren't
used to being able to just get anything
you wanted by going on them online and
getting that [ __ ] off a [ __ ] Amazon
or whatever and you weren't used to like
not knowing the answers to something you
know you didn't know you just but well
the thing is though that I you know
intellectually I remember what it was
like back then but it's like it's been
this way for so long now the
it's like I can't really cast my mind
back to you know and I mean it's it's
really hard for me to think about I
remember when I was first getting into
the Internet I got internet [ __ ] web
TV so I can order [ __ ] off the [ __ ]
hot topics like yes look we have all of
this technology at our fingertips
fingertips I want some janko's although
you didn't you know big happy anchors
yeah anywhere chicas didn't have Chico's
yet real Goths it'll work I gotta tell
you guys a story about janko's no it
wasn't about janko's but it was about
the fake janko's that they sold it [ __ ]
the big ass pain okay I feel like it's
become kind of like a thing like Xerox
at this point what happen if it's not
that for a while they had goth kids of
these big-ass [ __ ] black gothic
romance tonight yeah they all [ __ ]
pastors well a friend of mine a friend
of mine out in [ __ ] Gulfport
Mississippi name was Melissa all right
and her sister Michelle
Melissa worked for Hot Topic and she was
like one of their number one store
managers in the whole south yeah and
this is during this time Hot Topic was
pretty much god yeah bad nose remember
that remember that era and everybody
that ran it at that time the upper
executives were [ __ ] Goths yeah and
Melissa was had to go went on this big
meeting this is before you could have an
online meeting you actually had to go to
a meeting back there like I think she
went to that [ __ ] man was it Atlanta I
don't remember you know this all off the
top my head she goes there there's
always got people there in the [ __ ]
hotels you know and they're they're down
in the conference room in the hotel
and they're talking about they have to
make up some new products of new
products their daily [ __ ] yeah I'm
trying to tell us now
it's like look at my body anyway
she goes to this big meeting and hand
this girl who's in charge of most of the
purchasing the fashion decisions you
know and [ __ ] of what they're gonna sell
and they basically were making fun of
people at Mall kids yeah at that time
you know there's and they're wearing
these big-ass [ __ ] pants you know
they're just kind of [ __ ] laughing at
this janko's and they're gonna work at
it and we're gonna make a gothic version
of that they'll buy that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] Melissa and this girl sit there
and sketched out a design to make those
very first [ __ ] huge goth [ __ ]
pants yeah and they were laughing
they're [ __ ] like they would never
[ __ ] wear some [ __ ] like that
alright that rave stuff was totally in
the opposite direction
what off was all about it be like I like
mixing country-western and hip-hop
yeah just couldn't do it okay they did
it though and after they [ __ ] came
out of the design it came with a bunch
of these ideas for a bunch of products
they were just [ __ ] laughing about
this is what we're gonna have to do is
we're gonna have a competition going you
guys [ __ ] you know try to dress up
some [ __ ] mall kids as worse as you
[ __ ] kid sent us a [ __ ] picture
you know whoever whoever [ __ ] makes
the dumbest looking kid you you get a
$500 bonus so after that you know I mean
months later the [ __ ] products start
coming yeah
and they had an ability to take like
[ __ ] um in those days you could take
a picture on a what a digital camera
yeah and you could [ __ ] send it on
you know in 1994-1995 I think that's
like that must've been around 96
actually 95 yeah I'm trying to think
when I got my first digital camera I
think that was right around minus 96 and
that's about time janko's were around
[ __ ] so they just told me that they were
just [ __ ] grabbing kid you don't have
kids so they just try to get into the
second goth tag right and they [ __ ]
push them over to the Jenko so they
wouldn't give you cutting edge god fast
they give him the big-ass [ __ ] pad so
just come up with this ridiculous suck
and [ __ ] and then they took a picture
the kid is sitting walking down the mall
like that and it was just it was kind of
cruel but I'm just telling you don't
trust [ __ ] corporations there laughs
and also protip don't trust elder Goths
because we are the biggest [ __ ] yeah
and then what's funny is like [ __ ]
years later you don't I mean I'm going
to the [ __ ] club and I just see more
and more of these [ __ ] everywhere
with these [ __ ] big-ass [ __ ] big
[ __ ] Jenko style [ __ ] golf pants I
mean then that started and then that
went that even went into the into the
rave scene well yeah waivers right not
ready boys are talking about the [ __ ]
industrial yeah you know that graver
industrial type scene and [ __ ] all
started on the back of some [ __ ] goth
chicks joke yeah thanks a lot for
ruining our [ __ ] you combined yes you
got admitted it's pretty funny what
maybe it was a good sense they sold goth
stuff yeah and Bubba Jenkins were
selling yes they said we're gonna make
Gaga version yeah but they were laughing
at him yeah when they made him well
rightfully so because that was some wack
looking bull
well that's what I mean and I think that
that's like maybe if you're like you
know weren't in the scene or didn't grow
up in or whatever there was like a big
thing like in the 90s between people
that had gotten into goth in the 80s and
really into the old-school [ __ ] before
after Manson yeah before after manthan
and we were talking about that the other
day yeah and the [ __ ] that happened
after Marilyn Manson and then suddenly
you had like all these [ __ ] 15
year-olds coming out these gigantic
[ __ ] pants and like oh it's kind of
[ __ ] and we just like hated those kids
yeah we're just like what the [ __ ] are
you even doing here it's dinner and then
Columbine shooting happened around that
[ __ ] time and then it's like in the
whole world [ __ ] came back any of
those kids weren't even government
really all they had was like [ __ ]
trench coats
yeah which but that wasn't particularly
yeah it's like so
what the [ __ ] that was all about but
yeah poor Kate I know she's so cute she
just always wants to be on camera I did
not see the stroll of the kiddie
stroller people today I went out a
little bit earlier than usual so maybe
they hadn't got there yet at the Pooky
Pooky Caban cuz like i said we just like
think of a random song and they try to
insert pokey in the lair there's a
Pookie he knows oh she's buying the
stairway to heaven she loves it since
their mom's even though she's ignoring
it
so yeah let's see what else is going on
oh I got like a package today I got
here's my new memory where my Mac laptop
I'm gonna like install that [ __ ]
tomorrow I'm kind of like scared to
unscrew the bottom of it but I guess
yeah and also somebody in the YouTube
comments a while back and I think I
mentioned it had recommended this book
to me the Egypt game by self acutely
Schneider who also wrote the headless
Cupid which isn't my favorite books
growing up and I think they recommended
this to me cuz I was talking about one
of my board games that was about ancient
Egypt and they said I'd be really into
this so I went ahead and ordered it it's
like 50 speaking of board I finished the
ancient age of twin
like I said all of these are not gonna
go up until later this year because I'm
I have a whole bunch of games done but I
have to upload them to game crafter and
they're closed down for a little while
and then I have to order proofs of them
like I have to order the games and make
sure they're all correct
and then I can put them up for sale so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do like
by the end of the year man have like a
just a website that has all the games on
it that you can buy I'm working on
another one just like a little bit at a
time because I've been working on the
show and I mean working on my book and
[ __ ] like that today but I have another
one that I'm very excited about and it's
gonna be like a like a Halloween like a
trick-or-treat kind of game I did it
around I based it around like an urban
legend about a little town that loved
Halloween and then there was a
murder and now the little kids want to
go trick-or-treating again so I'm gonna
have a little thing where it's like you
can have your little character and like
you can get cards and like put little
costumes on them and [ __ ] like that so
I've been working on that just a little
bit at a time and I'm kind of having fun
with it
somebody in the comments section said it
was actually a bodybuilding channel I
forgot the name of the channel though
asked me wanted to know more about no
sir Thomas's predictions about the
apocalypse in the end of the world that
we're seeing now in the apocalypse and
the channel I could talk about that [ __ ]
all day long I'd get in trouble though
the channel the channel is supposed to
be kind of a neutral channel where
everybody can come and have fun and the
apocalypse involves so many [ __ ] so
much politics that people would get
[ __ ] pissed off and then you know how
YouTube is YouTube is [ __ ] try to
stifle the [ __ ] channel Jenny get mad
at me you know Jenny I don't don't agree
on politics they have totally different
view point on what's happening a
different interpretation of what's
happening so just because I say
something I don't want that to represent
the entire channel so but so I had to be
careful what I must say I must tell you
this about the apocalypse a house
divided against itself surely cannot
stand the situation is so polarized
you've seen this in history through
other arm in other countries elections
not going to work anymore and this is
what's happened in other countries they
get this sighs because every election
now will be a [ __ ] life-and-death
[ __ ] struggle between the right and
the left and and there's always going to
be a loser and the losing side is always
going to say oh there's something not
right this isn't fair so these two
forces can't exist in the same space and
either one or two things gonna happen
one side is gonna have to kill the other
off or they're gonna have to separate
into more than one country and that's
probably what will happen maybe a little
bit of both but I think eventually what
will happen
I think it's likely that eventually the
United States goes the way of the Soviet
Union where it probably would split up
maybe for different regions north east
west south and a Midwest hmm and be
groups of states now it probably keep
the peace for a while then maybe 50 60
70 years later those two those countries
will start waging war against each other
that's just that's why if you this why
the world is the way that it is people
think this shit's [ __ ] special it's
not special if you look at the globe you
look at the countries on the globe it's
a constant pattern of little countries
swallowing up other little countries and
becoming big countries that swallow up
other big countries and then it becomes
a big country that breaks into four
little countries and then they start
swallowing it's go look at the [ __ ]
borders of all the countries of the
earth and and now and go backwards [ __ ]
in two thousand years and look at how
those borders have changed in the past
two thousand it's never gonna stop
never well it's human nature is not it's
just not going to mean unless something
radical happens with technology or with
some kind of breakthrough and technology
will accelerate the struggle yeah no I
meant technology in the sense that you
know for example you can like have a
chip in your brain or something like
that I'm saying that kind of like bio
kind of [ __ ] yeah I said it you know
unless unless something like that
happens I mean humans are essentially
the same as they were yes they always
were and if some same damned forces and
it's gonna be this way forever yeah I
mean they're a bit better but I but by
better it's like I think the the
improvements are incremental right they
do happen but it's you know they're
quite small what's what's happening
right now is you're dealing with
generation of people in the West now
it's not just the United States it's the
West even in Brazil in certain parts of
central South America have cada been
educated to believe in or to have hope
in something that's never going to
happen and that that that is a one-world
government and it's all gonna be kumbaya
that will never happen if there was ever
a one-world government it could not be
democratic because it wouldn't work if
it was democratic if it was democratic
then it would be the power of the vote
and that would mean a tyranny of the
masses and if you look at who the
average person is on the damn planet one
of the biggest groups are the Chinese
alright and if they're voting and that
they always win the elections the United
States and the [ __ ] rest of the world
would be China
it'd be run like China and of course the
women aren't going like that and if it
wasn't the Chinese to be running the
show it would be the Middle East in his
Lomb and they would demand everyone
follow the [ __ ] rules of Islam the
bigger the organization is the lesser
chance you're gonna get everybody to
[ __ ] and agree with it on the same
page Americans cannot even agree on any
of this [ __ ] some of them want God some
of them doe some of them [ __ ] want
abortion some of them don't you're just
not gonna get these people to agree and
so that's why this isn't gonna work here
in the US this is all a fantasy you're
just seeing a natural process you're not
gonna have a situation where one group
votes to take the guns away it's not
gonna have them you're not gonna have a
situation where one groups votes to take
abortion away that's not going to happen
they're not gonna get along it just
can't happen and especially when you
really get down to it when you get down
to it the only reason why that voting
makes any difference because behind that
vote is guns or fists because as soon as
people get disenfranchised everyone will
[ __ ] that election does this [ __ ]
pick up a gun you know that's and secede
that's what history is about that's
that's how new countries are born
so this dreamer lads this dreamer idea
of
no college students getting elected with
no experience and telling everybody what
to do it's gonna be like this no it's
not no it's not Mao Zedong's said it the
best [ __ ] political peril their
political power comes from the barrel of
a gun either the soldiers have the guns
or the people have the guns it's just
whatever it is it's the guns and then
you're not gonna just say a highly
leftist government gets elected in and
then they tell the US army to disarm the
population or to oppress the people on
the right the Army's not gonna do it
they're all recorte and recruited from
the south so there's no enforcement
method most of the guys in the fighting
in the combat arms divisions are guys
from the south who vote Republican
they're not gonna do that they'll turn
right around shoot him and shoot their
leaders and it wouldn't be political it
wouldn't be military leaders be
political leaders and this is that same
theme that goes throughout all of human
history just that people do not agree so
that's all i'ma say about the apocalypse
well yeah like I said people that have
never agreed they've never agree mean
but I would rather that than have
everybody like if everybody thought the
same thing that would be even right but
you can't have a group of people saying
that they just want diversity but
everyone has to agree with them those
two things don't go together you can't
say I want diversity but then say but we
have to get rid of these people because
we don't like them and that's what's
happening with at least I see on the
Left we want diversity but we don't like
these guys they're racists we have to
kill them because they don't agree with
us we're gonna get the army to kill them
the arms no no they're not get the [ __ ]
out of here and if you look on online
who's saying this and if you look in
demonstrations of who's saying this is
some twenty-year-old college student
with a [ __ ] social studies degree and
they can't get a job that's not just
saying this it's just because most of
the [ __ ]
most of the woody column the
institutions of the United States over
the years have just kind of degenerated
into scams they just they don't do what
they originally did and they're just
making money and the people who run all
this most of them don't even live here
and they got Islands and they're like
[ __ ] Jeffrey Epstein they don't go
[ __ ] about us if this [ __ ] all goes bad
they'll just rot they all got [ __ ]
houses in [ __ ] New Zealand let's just
take them buddy run and it's poor
leadership same thing that happened in
the Roman Republic and the Roman Empire
now some people going well you know this
is a lot like the fall of Roman Empire
no it's not there's a lot of differences
what's happening right now actually
looks a lot more like the end of the
Roman Republic in the beginning of the
empire
you had the Roman Republic they went out
and sent sent their armies all around
the dam their version of the globe they
got into this long war with Carthage
they [ __ ] toppled Carthage brought a
whole bunch of slaves back to work with
work for them back in Rome and they used
those slaves to run all the rich people
used them to insource labor into into a
slave market basically inside Rome and
when that happened the soldiers that
were promised a [ __ ] farm when they
got out of their 20-year service
couldn't get a farm because they
couldn't they couldn't compete against
the slaves that were owned by the guys
who sent to war so nowadays that would
be kind of the equivalent of like an
outsourcing so well when this happened
of course of a populace uprisings and
that brought in a civil war happened and
that brought in julius and he got
assassinated and then romans [ __ ]
tore each other apart for many more
years they would kill each other over
who should run the empire and then well
actually julius got killed and then his
stepson are not a stepson his adopted
son Octavian became Augustus Octavian
proudly killed him because he had the
most to gain from it really but then he
spent years [ __ ] hunting down
traitors who killed his who killed
Julius and then there
a long reign of Caesars something more
good some of them were bad and that just
became a welfare state and kind of
totalitarian and in certain ways and
they had slave labor which inhibited the
growth of technology and eventually you
start getting down to where the money
started to devalue and they just started
hiring foreigners to replace their own
army because nobody believed in the in
the empire and they didn't want to serve
in its legions and then those foreign
mercenaries turned on the Empire and
tried to take over you know Rome got
sacked several times then eventually
just said I'll just said [ __ ] it it all
became a local be like states breaking
up from the United States and becoming
their own countries and that brought in
the medieval age you know but I don't
think that's happening now I think
probably what's happening is you're kind
of gonna because of technology it
happens faster now so maybe you could
have the fall of the Republic the
beginning of an empire and then the
collapse of an empire within a few
generations may be difficult to say
because back then things took longer to
happen they just didn't have a
technology telecommunications and they
didn't have didn't have steam engines so
no trains no mass transit so it's
difficult to say it's just it's it's bad
well like I said I don't ever speculate
about that kind of thing because there
are too many contingencies in
particularly particularly now when you
know like you said technology is
advancing to such a degree that you have
no idea like what newest technological
advancement is around the corner like no
one really predicted you know the effect
that the internet would have and [ __ ]
like that so I you know I I just I don't
know I just find it pointless to
speculate about what's gonna happen it's
a-you know I can't do anything about it
I'm just like a little bitty person and
so I just kind of like have to wait and
see what happens and then just kind of
roll with whatever goes on you know what
I mean the real problem is the
infrastructure can you keep enough
electric power and enough internal
combustion to produce electric power to
keep your homes running and running 3d
printers and doing the Internet
because a lot of the industry event
eventually will be replaced by Internet
3d printing at home but you still have
to have food production which there's a
lot of problems of food reduction right
now the developed world won't feel it
but the third world will the Africa
could starve without us producing and
evidently there's already food shortages
in South Africa and you know they got
people here playing games behind opening
up you know they don't want to open up
because they just they want they don't
want Trump to win this next election so
they're doing everything they can to
[ __ ] make him look bad they don't
care if [ __ ] those people in Africa
starve
that's [ __ ] I think so well I mean
that's [ __ ] that you said that I
listen to the damn I listen to those
reporters every day during those [ __ ]
briefings and that's all they do is tell
him who are you to open the economy back
up I'm like well who are you not to tell
him not to do it you know he's got to
open it up
well eventually it has to be opened up
but they do have to take now they do
have to take advice over because you
don't want it to be like Spanish flu
where they thought that it kind of went
away and then they started opening some
stuff up in some cities and then there
was a second wave that killed like a
bunch more people and like you enjoyed
it even further I know that but just so
they're they're kind of just trying to
mitigate I don't trust the experts
because well I would trust the experts
before I would trust a politician that's
perfect ensure I trust those caskets
there's not enough dead people they're
not dying from it enough the mortality
isn't as high as they thought they
expected between 10 and 13 percent more
fatality it's more like a tenth of a
percent that's about like a normal flu
well the problem too is that they don't
have enough tests and they're only
testing people that are sick enough to
come in for coming into the emergency
room at least in most places so some
people might be dying of it and they
don't know about it I don't that's not I
really don't think it matters there's
still not enough it's better because if
you don't get it running everyone can
die yeah but like you know but like I'm
saying they have to mitigate it because
you don't want it to be worse a couple
months from now you know what I mean so
you know there's no way to predict
exactly
it's gonna happen they're just trying to
err on the side of caution you look at
who's dying it's mostly people in their
80s that's the average age I'd say
[ __ ] you know you just have to be
practical
yeah but like you know yeah I'm sick
that's fine I'm just saying that you
have to understand too that it's like no
this is a new situation sort of and they
don't really know what's gonna happen
they're just trying to make it so that
it's not like two months from now it's
even worse than now and then they have
to end up doing all the [ __ ] again
but more stringently you know what I'm
saying you can say with as much
conviction as you want I don't think
it's [ __ ] well I don't know you can
think whatever you want that doesn't
have a say okay no that doesn't have
anything to do with what's really
happening or what's gonna happen I know
there's not enough dead people the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] hospitals are not
full enough which that tells you
something right they're just it's just
not it's not a big deal
yeah people are gonna die but they
always die and it's gonna be mostly old
people we have to keep a civilization
running there's always acceptable losses
oh yeah I know that but like I said you
have to understand that like some people
are coming at it from like they don't
want it to be worse later all right
all I'm saying this is this is the this
is the this is the crux of the problem I
think there's different kind of people
in this world people that because if I
don't know if it's upbringing or it's
genetics or what it is you know people
will look at a problem and you'll
basically they'll follow on two
different lines the way they are
perceiving that problem and the best way
to solve it like a fight if you have a
bad date and it's hard to get the
band-aid off you've pulled off real fast
and do it slowly some people are gonna
say pull it [ __ ] off fast other one's
gonna say pull it slowly it's probably
both right but in the case when you're
talking about a system that involves an
economy and a food production now you
pull that [ __ ] off quick yeah bunch of
people who will die but so what they're
gonna die anyway we're all gonna die
anyway eventually duh you know so what
does it what difference does it make I
was ready to die of [ __ ] 19 well good
for you I'm joining going war [ __ ] you
know I mean [ __ ] that's just the way
it is
it's it it's you have to have that
mindset to keep this [ __ ] running
we're expendable they're telling us that
they're saying well you're non-essential
personnel just stay home we don't really
need you
civilization doesn't need you that was
the plan all along
we're expendable technology made us all
obsolete they give a [ __ ] they're gonna
replace us all the robots in AI anyway
well I'm not really we were created they
created our grandparents and our parents
during that [ __ ] baby boom working in
their industries the plan was is that we
were going to work for them as they
expanded forever but of course
technologies can but they couldn't I
wouldn't [ __ ] expansion we created too
many of these people with these [ __ ]
are obsolete they just want to inherit
the earth it's gonna be just like that
[ __ ] out of [ __ ] Blade Runner or you
know [ __ ] was it name again
Prometheus where you're gonna have these
trillionaires and they're gonna be
surrounded by a bunch of replicants or
robots things that they made because
they're better than us they you know
smarter like classical music and [ __ ]
like David remember that robot David
yeah that's what they want well they
definitely don't want me they definitely
don't want me no xanga listen to them
Tommy listen [ __ ] well you know it's
good well it's kind of hard to wrap this
up now since you went all like
depressing and not depressing man this
is just this is what people wanted to
hear that Burton wanted to hear and I
don't want to talk anymore about it you
said that like ten minutes ago and they
kept on talking he does that all the
time he's just kind of like I don't want
to talk about it anymore
and then like half an hour later I'm
saying this [ __ ] man she lives with this
[ __ ] that's what I mean these yeah it's
like well maybe I don't talk to her
about it though well you do know
yeah oh I'm back in work you don't want
to hear this [ __ ] so I just let you
watch movies and [ __ ] oh well yeah
that's what I mean I work all day yeah I
don't you guys work a different way you
know I read news and [ __ ] - but it's
like then after that I got to get [ __ ]
done I can't like spend all day like
worrying about that kind of [ __ ] cuz
it's like there's nothing I can do about
this in the news I tell you what the
news is I don't need you to tell me what
the news is I don't need you to tell me
I don't need like some returned on
YouTube telling me either I can read it
one retards on YouTube I don't need ya
but I don't do the news or news some of
us all do news well no that's what I
mean it's like a for Britney if I want
news I will read it I don't need
somebody like talking at me you know
what I mean so it's like I'll just read
it but I usually just read it once a day
cuz like I said you know there's nothing
I can do about it right now it's like
all I can really do is just keep doing
my [ __ ] and like hope I don't die which
you know that's kind of like the
situation I've been in for a long time
it's like it was you know so I got your
back okay well what if I'm out for a
walk and like I get run over by a truck
or something
you won't gonna have my back and
recharge it cuz I was in that walk away
well yeah that's what me I gotta go up
by myself sometimes you don't get up
early me for not being with you no I
didn't blame me I'm just saying that in
that situation there wouldn't be
anything you can say about their manners
all kinds of people out there walking
well I know that but it was what if it
what if like a truck like went Korean
like you went out of control or
something you think I can stop a truck
come on I'll [ __ ] you big bag I thought
that big like a meteor could follow my
headers' you [ __ ] you know what I mean
I'm just saying that I'm just saying
that you can't like categorically say
that you have my back because things
like that happen you know what I mean
you see the [ __ ] I put up with people I
know I'm the worst she [ __ ] picks on
me I did well because you pick on me all
the time - and then you're always like
you're Suzette's and if you're so
sensitive that's how guys talk to each
other I'm like one I'm not a guy and so
you know what I mean so then like so I
started picking on him back so I started
picking on him back and he doesn't like
it I was like see it sucks doesn't it
[Laughter]
all right it's a long enough one week
holy [ __ ] oh yeah we would not let this
just [ __ ] long oh this is a whole
episode
well not quite it's only 33 minutes like
our regular episodes they're our last
ones are like [ __ ] three and a half
years listening to us [ __ ] well they
don't business I think so you know I got
the camera bedroom we can get the
cameras hit now ever see that the
swagman one of these days I'm gonna show
him a swashbuckler booth I didn't a
dancefloor what you did I remember that
I think it started [ __ ] you've done
it more than once I think actually
thinking about it cuz that's like your
patented that's my fanfiction I never
actually did it to enjoy this would
wildly off this channel [ __ ] BAM
you're gonna get D monitor well it's
like we already have limited
monetization on some of the videos
because they're about serial killers and
stuff and they limited the month well
they you can still get monetization but
you don't get as much because that you
can't have welcome what kid-friendly ads
and [ __ ] on there I haven't got anything
like completely divided all right ad
revenue is only like a hundred bucks a
month something like that but you know
we don't really do for the ad revenue
though well no I only just started mana
you to be really a creator friendly
place like it was I mean you know like I
said a you know that we would [ __ ]
have [ __ ] done as a thousand [ __ ]
subs and we making all kinds of money
but they wanted all that [ __ ] they
weren't all the traffic to go to quote
authoritative sources well I kind of
thought that the ones that were making a
lot of money back in the old days it was
ones that were mostly geared toward of
this younger audience because clickbait
well it was one it was clickbait it was
like video game type like just kids
playing video
I'm like swearing at each other and [ __ ]
like that it was okay it was all kind of
[ __ ] that like adults wouldn't watch
their [ __ ] use their giving money on
their mom's credit card to people yeah I
kind of feel like that was that was most
of your like big youtubers and [ __ ] like
that cuz some of the ones that made yeah
there's some of the ones that made a lot
of money I'm like really people watch
that okay I'm that's like I'm not hating
you know we we sit there and watch dudes
walk around malls with nobody I don't
know how PewDiePie got big I like Peter
pie but I don't think he's that funny I
think he's a douche but you know I I can
see why he's popular but the thing is I
I can see why he's popular but if he's
popular I don't know why equally douchey
people didn't get just as popular yeah I
don't get that
cuz there's even a couple channels at
which cuz I mostly watched like you know
horror channels like you know movie
review channels [ __ ] like that there's a
couple of them that I like but I can
only watch them in small doses cuz they
like just always yelling and I hate that
or the editing is like super or like
like really a DD and it's like I know
I'm old but it's I can stand like some
of that but I don't like yelling I don't
like people that are just like yelling
about everything I'm just like shut up
but yeah so um what the hell's today
it's Thursday right yes yes one of those
days it's one what one of the days and I
had repairman over here doing [ __ ] and
everything he asked me what day it is
there's day to watch he's dudes work did
he did he fix the dryer makes the dryer
and makes the kiddie things oh there was
two guys yeah dude I knew that was like
I'd come here and like noise and drills
and stuff yeah we had like one of those
you know one of those like environments
that you like mount on the wall that has
like little shelves and little dryer
would say 175 bucks but yeah it has like
all these little like perches and
hammocks and [ __ ] yeah and I guess
either Beijing or Pooky I'm assuming
it's Beijing because she's bigger she's
straight-up broke one of those posts it
came out of the wall I get pulled out of
the driveway I came here the hammer
drill and put it right through the
concrete it's it's it's a matter of well
now it's not going anywhere and Beijing
is not that bad no she's not fat if did
still a 15 pound cat
I thank God yeah Pookie is about ten
pounds I think but they jump on it so
rigorously they're always like chasing
each other up in it and like fighting
and stuff so I guess that's probably why
she broke it a couple days ago
oh um watched a video last night what
was name of that one yeah that's what I
was gonna that's what I was trying to
say before you went off on your little
tangent um yeah one of the movies that
Marcus said yeah yeah chef Marcus Marcus
it was called incarnate incarnate yeah
it was pretty good yeah it was that
right it is one of those blum house
movies I looked up I thought it was
older than it was it actually came out
in 2016
okay kind of like a possession movie but
with like a different little bit of a
different twist to it yeah it's kind of
like imagine you have Chuck Norris going
around doing possessions doing exercise
do it exorcisms yeah but he calls them
evictions evictions yeah like action
movie with a tough guy [ __ ] dude this
guy's cool
Aaron Eckhart was he's been like in a
[ __ ] ton of stuff he was in Midway was
it he liked to see Midway yeah I
remember him being in this the good
thing about him though is that you know
you're getting into in you West blow him
house movies they're kind of like a
[ __ ] upscale episode of the haunting
that's it yeah
well now Blum has come up with some
really really good movies yeah I think
Invisible Man like I said I think that
was my house but you know most of their
movies are like the mediocre to good I
think but but they have like a really
successful business model which is we're
gonna make a horror movie for less than
ten million dollars yeah and they pretty
much always make their money back yeah
they just keep the quality high yeah
high enough although I have to say you
guys the movie was this a plumb house
movie the bye-bye man because that movie
was kind of shadow I don't know if it
was blonde house or not there was a
trailer for it on this movie on the
movie that we watched last night and I
was like man was that Blom house sent
over because I think I watched it on
shutter Netflix or something and you
know me like and I've said this on
several movie reviews it's like even if
a movie isn't that good I will usually
watch the whole thing through that one I
just stopped watching it and I was like
man [ __ ] it I just like turned it off
and I just
I gotta say in general bloom house is
better than a new hammer I've been
seeing those hammer movies aren't that
good although I think that the remake of
The Woman in Black was hammer and that
was very good if you see that one I saw
it
how do you see I have it on DVD or blue
on the other hand the other newer Hammer
movie said they weren't that good which
one was which one was hammered the lodge
yeah I liked that one
but like I said there they're trying to
go I guess a more a 24 direction where
they're trying to do more like art house
yeah or art houses are like slower
because the woman in black is like kind
of a classic ghost story type thing a
British movie alright so we've gone on
long enough so I guess we'll wrap it up
for this Thursday have a good rest of
your day and we'll talk to you again
tomorrow